A long time ago, Urashima had three daughters
.
Back when the island was connected to the mainland, there was an
older brother named
Yukino
in Rinne.
That's why I despised the love of two people who strayed from the path,
and even asked a hidden black shrine maiden to tear it apart.The
black cat put a curse on morality and turned into a beast
.  In Rin, she took her own life
out of grief.In the remaining moments, she took advice from Sara, who was in the new building,
and immediately visited the black shrine maiden on the phantom island
and signed a contract
.  After
that, Setsuna fell asleep in the ice and continued to wait
for that day.In the moment, which continues to watch over beyond the endless flow of time, there are three thousand worlds.  As a guardian of
the , I was given the sex
of the last
time.